and now it's time for bumming reviews
and if Chester a bum
tonight's review baby it's boy this boy
called dustpan he used to be a common
thief on the streets but then the king
came along visit I had nothing better to
do submission of Prince became a prince
that way once wit he's very desperate
for credible royalty Joe just big grows
up to be the Prince of Persia saw him in
the other Prince's go to invade this
town college I see Bill and Princess
pain gets into the town by putting them
on a stick push another good midgets use
a ladder is this before I advanced
ladder technology no gears and it's porn
where they come across princess he was
actually protecting this ancient dagger
that can make you travel through time
all you have to do is lit up the sinned
in the dagger Oh doc what'd you do
Barney
it runs on the Preakness to get the King
this wonderful group is poison robe yeah
for his murder
compress once they didn't like me
because I only had three arms and they
didn't really like the third one so he
must ban the fees to the most horrible
thing possible ostrich racing again
totally that joking there's ostrich
racing in the Prince of Persia what
denied deep I need to step so the river
the princesses deep doctor octopus's
evil ostriches I finally figure out the
game kill the king
it was the guy who played Johnny it's a
murderer baby still there is something
wrong with that Daddy Cool's which shave
his head and wear a diaper all day don't
get any means of destroying the Prince
of Persia so he comes across these emo
goth assassins oh my like you snakes and
Twilight you kill the weights of
pressure for me that's dark
yeah give it in so it turns out the
dagger can only take you back like a
minute in time so they need the sense of
time to go even further the which kind
of looks like a giant flaming cheetah so
the Brits in the princess Gandhi Doctor
Octopus is what remaining ostrich no
hurry so Prince of Persia is the
greatest videotape of you for me but
probably because it's the only good
videotape movie ever made I mean you hit
the brain saying you could have been
directed by you people
any thief who's the main shall not be
mentioned
I like pork this is jittery boom see
what I mean by a giant baby Chino don't
we see what so curiously hot